le front national est le premier parti
de france sur dans l'ensemble de la
france
maintenant ce que nous voudrions c'est
transformer l'essai et faire en sorte
que le front national soit aussi le
premier parti des yvelines et pour ce
faire le parti de marine le pen a
mobilisé pour cette départementale ses
candidats élus les plus emblématiques
tels que le maire de mantes la ville
syrie notre le seul maire fn
ile-de-france qui tentera de faire
barrage à pierre bédier
mais également des conseillers
municipaux il était logique que nous
nous présentions notamment les personnes
élues sur le sur les élections
départementales
en tant qu'ancien militaire et ancien
gendarme je suis très sensibilisés par
la sécurité je crois qu'aujourd'hui
c'est véritablement un des points
faibles du gouvernement et les thèmes
son nationale parce que forcément je
crois que que les français sont en
attente de quelque chose de fort qui
n'arrive pas une migration chômage
insécurité enfin tous les échecs de
l'ump du ps depuis 40 ans d'autres sont
plus nouveau politique comme eric jégo
est elle de oliviera tout juste 19 ans
ces valeurs qui nous ont été transmis à
la fac qui m'a donné l'envié de
m'engager au front national
liberté égalité fraternité c'est une
notion aussi des notions qui sont
abstraites pour de mon point de vue on
peut pas aller retrouver dans
l'actualité ou même dans notre vie
quotidienne
j'aimerais un peux apporter ma pierre
à tout ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
puisque pour moi en fait le peuple
français est un peu lâché la jeunesse
des candidats c'est sur ce point que
veut aussi miser le front national pour
ces élections
à l'image de perim jauniaux adhérents du
front national à 16 ans et candidate à
18 ans seulement
je montre l'exemple aux jeunes qu'aux
espaces présenté au front national
l'immigration le euros l'insécurité il
chômage
je pense très sincèrement que le front
national est la seule alternative
possible non seulement au niveau
national mais aussi au niveau local
surtout des problèmes déjà de travail
prennent de précarité dans le travail
problème de chômage problèmes de
logement la sécurité un thème récurrent
pour les candidats moi je suis
commerçante
j'ai 46 ans et je vois énormément de
misère autour de moi et clients qui se
plaignent les 2 to de la sécurité
beaucoup de leurs aussi beaucoup
commencent à étouffer je m'engage un
petit peu plus parce que je voudrais
quand même que que les choses bougent un
peu parce que bon je me reconnais plus
tellement dans ces 62 ans et je
reprenais plus du tout la france en 2011
lors des dernières cantonales le front
national avait présenté des candidats
dans chacun des cantons renouvelables